WASHINGTON.
THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
IT'S BEEN A BIG NEWS DAY HERE IN
THE NATION'S CAPITOL.
AND IN NEW YORK CITY WHERE AN
HIS CHEST MALFUNCTIONED AFTER
DETONATION AT THE PORT AUTHORITY
SUBWAY STATION.
SURPRISE SURPRISE, HE GOT INTO
AMERICA VIA -- WAIT FOR IT --
CHAIN MIGRATION.
SO ISN'T IT TIME TO DITCH THIS
ANCHOR JORGE RAMOS WHAT HE
THINKS OF THE DEBATE OF CHAIN
MIGRATION.
AND WITH ACCUSATIONS OF PART
SEASONSHIP SURROUNDING THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
ANDY McCARTHY WILL BE HERE TO
EXPLAIN HOW THE MUELLER PROBE
MAY BE MISSING THE MOST
IMPORTANT RUSSIA STORY OF ALL.
BUT FIRST, THE MEDIA'S DESPERATE
ATTEMPT TO DIVERT ATTENTION FROM
THEIR REPEATED SCREW-UPS.
THAT IS THE SUBJECT OF TODAY'S
ANGLE.
IT WASN'T JUST ANOTHER FAKE NEWS
STORY ATTEMPTING TO TIE
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO RUSSIA.
CNN'S DISGRACEFUL REPORTING OF
LAST WEEK SEEMS LIKE A WATERSHED
MOMENT.
A BLATANT EXAMPLE OF THE
ESTABLISHMENT MEDIA'S RECKLESS
COVERAGE OF THE SO-CALLED RUSSIA
COLLUSION STORY.
ON FRIDAY, YOU'LL RECALL CNN
REPORTED THAT WIKILEAKS TRIED TO
SHARE HACK DOCUMENTS WITH THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND DON TRUMP JR.
IN SEPTEMBER OF 2016.
THAT REPORT WAS QUICKLY PICKED
UP BY OTHER NEWS ORGANIZATIONS.
BUT IT TURNED OUT, THOSE
DOCUMENTS HAD ALREADY BEEN MADE
PUBLIC AND THE DATES OF THE DON
IN CNN'S FACE.
CNN NEVER RETRACTED THE STORY,
BUT TOOK FIVE HOURS TO POST A
CORRECTION AFTER IT WAS
DEBUNKED.
ON SUNDAY, THE HOST OF CNN'S
RELIABLE SOURCES, BRIAN STETLER
DIDN'T EXPLAIN HOW THE STORY WAS
WRONG.
INSTEAD, HE TROTTED OUT CARL
TRUMP CRITIC, DAVID FROMM AND
SAID HOW CNN BOTCHED THE STORY.
THEY DID REVERT TO THE CNN PARTY
LINE AND THEY ATTACKED THE
PRESIDENT.
>> THE SOURCES WEREN'T TRYING TO
BLACK EYE FOR CNN.
>> JOURNALISTS MAKE MISTAKES.
THE STORY IS PRETTY GOOD,
ESPECIALLY COMPARED TO THE
RECORD OF DONALD TRUMP.
>> FROM THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
SUPPORTERS, YOU HIT HERE A
SYSTEM OF LIES.
SO THEY'RE NOT WELL-PLACED TO
COMPLAIN.
THE WORST MISTAKES THAT PRESS
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE COVERAGE OF
TRUMP HAS PRECISELY OCCURRED IN
THEIR EFFORT TO BE FAIR TO THE
PRESIDENT.
>> WAIT A SECOND.
NOW CNN CONCOCTS A DAMAGING
STORY ABOUT THE PRESIDENT AND
THEY ONLY DID SO BECAUSE THEY'RE
TRYING TO BE UTTERLY FAIR TO
I NEED TO BUY A MAJOR VOWEL OR
CREDIBILITY BY ALLOWING POLITICS
TO DOMINATE EDITORIAL DECISIONS
AND COLOR THEIR REPORTING.
BY THE WAY, IT'S NOT JUST CNN.
ABC'S BRIAN ROSS REPORTED THAT
CANDIDATE TRUMP INSTRUCTED
MICHAEL FLYNN TO REACH OUT TO
THE RUSSIANS WHEN IT WAS
ACTUALLY PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP.
OOPS!
HE TWEETED FROM THE TRUMP RALLY
SHOWING LOTS OF EMPTY SEATS.
BEFORE THE AUDIENCE HAD ACTUALLY
ENTERED THE ARENA.
NOT SURPRISINGLY, POLLS SHOW THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC IS LOSING FAITH
IN HOW THE MEDIA ARE COVERING
AMERICAN VOTERS DISAPPROVE OF
THE WAY THE MEDIA COVERS THE
PRESIDENT AND 38% APPROVE.
53% OF VOTERS SAID THE MEDIA
FOCUSES TOO MUCH ON NEGATIVE
STORIES ABOUT TRUMP.
SO THE MEDIA'S ANSWER TODAY?
MORE NEGATIVE STORIES ABOUT
TRUMP.
IN AN ATTEMPT TO REVIVE SOME
THE NETWORK DRAGGED OUT TRUMP A
CASERS.
THE PRESIDENT DENIED THE
ACCUSATIONS.
THAT DIDN'T STOP MEGYN KELLY
FROM SHOWCASING THEM ON HER
STRUGGLING MORNING SHOW.
SO MUCH FOR STAYING OUT OF
POLITICS.
DIDN'T SHE SAY SHE WAS GOING TO
DO THAT?
THEY HELD A PRESS CONFERENCE
HELD BY A GROUP CALLED "BRAVE
NEW FILMS."
PEEL BACK THE CURTAIN, BRAVE NEW
FILMS DESCRIBES ITSELF AS A
QUICK STRIKE MEDIA COMPANY THAT
HAS PRODUCED LIBERAL
DOCUMENTARIES.
TURNED TODAY'S WHITE HOUSE PRESS
BRIEFING INTO A TOTAL CIRCUS.
>> I WAS GOING TO ASK --
>> YOU USED IT ON SOMETHING
ELSE.
>> IF I MAY, SARAH --
>> I'M GOING TO KEEP MOVING.
>> IF I CAN ASK ABOUT THE OTHER
JIM'S ACCUSATION.
>> HAVE YOU EVER BEEN SEXUALLY
HARASSED AND DO YOU -- I'M NOT
SAYING BY THE PRESIDENT.
I'M SAYING EVER.
>> THIS IS SPINNING AND FOCUSED
OPEN HIM NOW.
>> AND HE'S ADDRESSED IT TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> AND MORE PEOPLE ARE SPEAKING
I TRYING TO COVER AS MANY OF YOU
AS I CAN.
>> THIS IS A HUGE ISSUE, SARAH.
>> Laura: NORTH KOREA.
BUT THIS IS A HUGE ISSUE.
A HUGE ISSUE OBSESSED IN DRIVING
TRUMP FROM OFFICE AT ALL COSTS.
ON THE DAY BEFORE THE ALABAMA
SENATE ELECTION, AS WE PREDICTED
LAST WEEK WHEN DEMOCRATS RAN AL
FRANKEN OUT OF THE SENATE,
WITHOUT SO MUCH AS A SCHEDULED
HEARING, SENATOR KIRSTEN
WEAKEN THE PRESIDENT WITH THESE
CHOREOGRAPHED ALLEGATION
PARADES.
THEY WON'T WORK.
AT LEAST NOW IT'S EASIER TO SEE
WITH WHOM CERTAIN MEDIA